all right so let's talk about what's
happening on the january 6th
what a segway yeah everyone's all sweet
january 6. well it's time to spice it up
come on yeah
heart cam hearts well what's going on
january 6 so they had an 8 o'clock prime
time hearing tonight which is i'm sure
already started and it was all about the
one it's supposed to be about the 187
minutes
that trump did nothing uh to stop the
riot
okay that's what it's about
but so i brought my notes because i had
to i had to make notes for this
would you say that uh uh look let me
preface this yeah i'll ask you a
question the way a cnn reporter would
ask the white house practice press
secretary
they would say um
congresswoman we know for a fact that
the january 6 committee lies
they lie often and they smear innocent
people uh notably this is cnn no no
yeah so so well how they would ask the
question right okay so so we know that
the democrats and the january 6
committee are lying about everything um
can you comment
oh
well that doesn't sound like cnn because
well no no no no but they do the inverse
of that they'll say okay they'll they'll
go out and they'll they'll give the
answer to the question to the president
not normally how they talk to me but
they'll say they'll say uh we know that
donald trump committed these crimes in
these crimes um uh so thank you for your
time and they'll sit down oh yeah there
it is and then they just flow in to give
all the information they
they they they present the uh the answer
in their question for the the white
house yes absolutely so yeah
well you have to do that for karine uh
because she she needs that help they
they have to she's really bad at this
this is like she's terrible jen seki was
actually a good spin doctor she was
great yeah like the she she was a good
spin doctor karine is just like someone
asks a question about biden doing
something horrible and she'll go oh he
did yeah she's like she's like flipping
through the book
yeah no
they're going the plausible deniability
route they're like don't tell her
anything because then she can't get
caught in a lie
so i mean what would you do if you were
her i would run off stage every day
crying so but in all seriousness though
look uh i'm obviously bitter because
jamie raskin included me to defame me in
his evidence but uh so tell us what's
going on and and what's happening with
these these current lines well i think
that what they're missing is
someone that's really important to the
entire day and that's ray epps
they want to blame president trump they
want to say that he caused it he told
people to do it but you know raps is on
camera telling people to do it literally
january 5th he's on video telling people
to go
in
to the capitol can i just can i just uh
to get personal
they include a clip of me reading a fox
news article and and claimed that was me
promoting trump's protest and they not
once have shown right ups literally
telling people to storm the capitol no
but they showed you so they they
slandered you
and they made you as if you were part of
of organizing
this this event that's supposed to be
the worst day in america these are evil
people yeah you should sue them you
can't speech and debate clause oh yeah
speech and debate that's right
yeah maybe we should bring you in tim
when we get our turn when republicans
take back the house well i can certainly
talk to that and be like here's a video
of me reading a news article and then
them accusing me of yeah we should give
you the opportunity to set the record
straight because that's not fair i mean
how many times have you guys been
swatted i'm sure that people think that
you're somehow part of some crazy
insurrection or something i i think
there are a lot of people who um
you know jamie was saying this it's the
it's the democrat version of the fox
news dad i guess you called it yeah it's
it's it's it's the people who turn on
cnn cnn and msnbc and then sit there
with their eyes glazed in their drool
point out of their mouth and they just
believe everything uncritically without
challenging it
yeah and then they're they're they they
live in the conspiracy and we still they
believed jesse smilet
and and were supposed to they're holding
a panel together
and they're the people who believe jesus
is like come on they can't govern i mean
you're nuts people forget the the rise
of fox news
happened after september 11th
and msnbc
was
you know had had anti-war voices on like
phil donahue right and immediately when
fox news became popular and they go okay
we need american flags we need patriotic
music we can't have any war and suddenly
you know the only debates you saw
against the war it would be like a
five-star general on the right and then
on the left it would be like janine
garofalo like it would just be like
these like terrible just like smash
debates to make the anti-war left just
look like a couple actors right right
and so then msnbc and cnn they had to
play catch-up because fox news was
getting all the ratings was just
smashing them and so then they became uh
you know at first they sort of became
the the the adversaries for fox news and
then
when i would say like probably when like
obama got elected they just became okay
now we're not necessarily
gonna push back now we're just just
party lines whatever that is but it was
the exact same tactics the exact same
music the exact same big personalities
the exact same stifling dissent blah
blah blah blah
all the networks do it now it's the same
but we're so used to because fox news
was first we're so used to just going ah
fox news oh that's classic fox news fox
news but what we don't realize on the
left is no no no msnbc they're hard left
they've all done it i want to say look
msnbc is crackpot conspiracy nonsense
big time fox news has some like
you you with fox news you've gotten a
bit of tucker carlson being like where's
ray epps what does this mean and the
media comes out and says he's a
conspiracy theorist for bringing up
right apps attacking him no he's not but
on msnbc they entertained rachel maddow
was like russia russia russia russia
russia for three years she nearly cried
when the mueller report came out that
trump didn't do it it's crazy remember
you see that video she's like
it's like wow your whole life is
breaking in front of your face maybe you
should have actually done research
instead of just lying yeah but the thing
is is is really a lot of news doesn't
represent regular people and how we
think so i've been a republican all my
life but when
when we went into iraq looking for
weapons of mass destruction
i was sitting here going why are we
going in iraq they were from saudi
arabia the 19 terrorists and then i'm
like well where's the weapons of mass
destruction did you ever find any no no
so everybody's going like what are we
doing i i mean i ask those questions
what are we doing that i hated it the
whole time and this is people got so
divided because i remember any time i
criticized the war even from the left
they would go you're anti-troop and what
i always explained is
anti-military that is a pro-military
pro-military and pro-american i don't
want you yes die because some
politicians don't know what they're
doing they're doing that especially when
they come home and they're not treating
ptsd and they're not getting the
benefits they deserve it's like being
anti and they're missing limbs yep that
is
they're changed forever 100 and jamie's
far right confirmed he's agreeing with
marjorie
how about how about my favorite uh when
barack obama drone-bombed a 16-year-old
american kid
i mean it's just the obama
administration they called him obama
it's amazing they called him the
deporter-in-chief
i pulled this up on on my segment
earlier today because we have we have
other news too we'll get into a second
that joe biden's approval rating
aggregate is lower than trump's lowest
point so biden has broken the record
this is the most popular he's number one
well history he's number one i want to
put a tag in there but so i was looking
at uh news
obama was 42 positive coverage 20
negative
and he literally executed an american
citizen without charge or trial the
media is
derelict in this country absolutely
during
during remember when the only scandal in
this country was a tan suit
i remember when he killed a kid
now
now the media has gone beyond derelict
and now they're complicit now they're
actively engaging in the psyops and the
manipulation of the american people to
defend criminals they are biden for
instance absolutely
both of them so i haven't introduced
articles of impeachment over and over
and over so excited when we brought him
out invited you lit up in your chair
that was great i can't believe it yeah
you want to know something i have to
tell y'all something yep remember the
iphone leak that just happened recently
hunter
iphone and icloud i think both right yes
someone it was in the middle of the
night someone sent me a telegram channel
and people had loaded that thing up with
contents of his icloud and iphone and i
saw things that i i wish they're like
nightmares in my head now i'm not
kidding you the man was always naked
sure um had sex with i i don't know how
many women
i uh women of the night
all kinds of women but yeah but there's
there's several videos that i
cannot get over and this is where it's
so
upsetting this was like your clockwork
orange
they were and i you know they were
probably 14 to 15 years old whoa
but is that all confirmed
that is me what i saw with my eyes and
making my own judgment i can't confirm
it you gotta you gotta just give all the
i'd say give to the fbi but i'm not no
you wanna know what happened
while i was going through the horrific
things and i'll tell you there was a
picture of a boy in a bathtub
that had to be
pre-teen somewhere in the early teens
preteen and we don't know if these are
real no i they're they looked 100 real
they were from but while i was going
through it the entire channel got
wiped clean everything disappeared
and was that telegram that did that
i don't know i can't tell you to this
day now i would never have saved any of
that stuff on my phone you want to know
why you'll get in trouble yes it's
illegal i remember people posting that
and it was like publicly available i
didn't click on it because i knew it
yeah it's horrible stuff it's horrible
stuff i feel like the the crack and the
prostitutes and everything like that is
just a distraction from the political
corruption though right yeah well
doesn't the drug use actually make
hunter biden more human like you
actually feel sorry for him because
drugs are horrible
drugs are horrible and they do horrible
things to people but having sex with
minors of course no no that's illegal
but then people focus on one thing
they're like you're
degrading this person for having a drug
problem and like yeah then
do you know how many people have seen
all that people empower people with
positions that can do something about it
and no one does anything
it's it's that is that's the part that i
can't take but there's even more to it
there's the same way there's that kind
of content there's also information on
business deals and banking information
and with foreign countries and this is
the president of the united states son
the and joe says that hunter is the
smartest guy he knows
like why are we all in this situation
that is my question as an american
why as american citizens why are we all
in this situation
and and why does why does our media
protect it thanks for checking out this
clip from timcast irl come hang out live
monday through friday at 8 pm eastern
time super chat we'll even answer some
of your questions if you want to check
out the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time